what is a rule of thumb you've
experienced over the years telling kids
your salary
because i really like having especially
my 11 year old down there watching us do
the budget and watching
because i want him to have an
understanding here's how much
electricity costs and water costs and
those kind of things
but also just having innate fear of him
running around school
saying hey what does your parents make
my parents you know what i mean yeah
i uh
you know i shared all the expenses but i
never shared the income okay
until they were 18 okay or until they
were in college or whatever
they knew we were doing okay you know
kind of thing but they
um uh i didn't but we were also trying
to protect our kids from the celebrity
crap as well
right you know they the um because we
were trying to make sure they don't play
the dave cart at school to try to get
some kind of
favor right now or something my dad's
dave ramsey you know that kind of bull
crap
and so you just got to step on that with
a big foot
and so um truthfully none of them ever
did it much except rachel
yeah i i i think my son lies about his
last name
no it's a delaney i'm not that guy right
well yeah and there's some of that i
mean because there's two sides to that
part
right i mean there's a lot of french
guys interference try try being in a
financial
uh a personal finance class in college
and your dad's name is dave ramsey yeah
that would be a pain in the butt
so that that really happened um didn't
go well
and so uh uh but yeah there's and i can
see rachel she won't back down either
no and yeah daniel would nod politely
rachel would say excuse me
daniel waited till the end of the
semester and then told the guy's last
name
right right he didn't even get it the
guy didn't even understand how stupid he
was but um
the uh uh but the yeah uh
no we didn't share incomes and
uh but it's protecting an
eleven-year-old from himself i think but
well and
you know they because they just um
you know they uh even if something is
the truth
you don't want them bragging that's
right you don't want them
uh embarrassing
themselves or the family or whatever
else i mean it's just
you don't want them being that kid you
know like rob you know my dad makes
sense
my mama makes sense though yeah you know
that's a gross kid but i like that idea
of of sharing the expenses making sure
they see this yeah they did i mean i
remember
distinctly rachel and uh
maybe denise sitting at the kitchen
table and we're going over the electric
bill and denise goes
oh my gosh it costs so much to buy
electricity
and like rachel looked at and goes i
guess that's why they're telling us
closed the door all the time
turn the lights off right it's like but
there was just no pun intended light
bulb moment that came on right and
um you know and it's just but that
that's really good
i love those conversations and you know
get the mutual fund
statement out and go here's the share
price and here's the number of shares in
your
college fund right and so how do you
figure out what your how much money is
in your college fund you multiply those
times each other
i love that and it's a little little
sixth grade math lesson
fourth grade math lesson there whatever
it is to get to that point and work that
through but it's value building
and uh and then you have to you know you
have to constantly correct
uh for them we just we squashed out
any type of entitlement oh yeah
stuff like rachel and i told the story
in the uh smart money smart kids series
in the book and in the
teaching series she does in ramsey plus
um
daniel was a little guy you know about
seven eight years old we finally got a
decent car
after going broke and you know and you
know we had an old we're old
southern people so you get a new car
everybody piles in you go for a little
ride right that's a
like a celebration of the buying the new
car you know what i'm talking about
yes and so daniel gets he leans back in
the back seat all the way back and he
goes
we're doing pretty good yeah and i said
honey
we ain't doing anything you got nothing
you got nothing
i'm doing pretty good you you're just
alone for the ride buddy
and so he's like the kids told that
story for years because like daniel's
like
okay okay i just thought it was like
when i got this latest truck
this this fine 06 model hank got in it
he looked at it he looked at me based on
the old truck i was driving yeah it's a
pretty sizable upgrade he said
dad are we rich yes we are so
yes we are we have a good used pickup
that's right
we are rich this truck cost five digits
not just uh not everybody has a
five-digit pickup
this truck had a 10 in front of the
comma
whoa dad that's right son stay close to
your old man he'll get you places
oh my gosh well the thing is yeah you do
want to share and
on the other side the other thing we run
into with kids how much to discuss is
when things aren't going well
right you don't want to scare them right
you can terrify kids yeah you can
terrify them
we're gonna get four clothes down and
thrown in this street
yes and that you know that's trauma that
they'll carry into their 40s
right you know but instead just go you
know
mom and dad got this it's gonna be okay
it's we're having some bad times though
and you just keep it where they can
digest it
and obviously you can disclose more to a
14 year old than you can a four-year-old
at least hypothetically
and um i've learned in those
conversations that touch
is a huge settling thing for a kid um if
i'm having a hard conversation with
with a young kid i'm going to sit them
on my lap i'm going to make sure i'm
touching their face touching their hands
and it's a grounding force for a kid
they can hear it and they can see me
right um
as opposed to just throwing off a piece
of information that i got more context
to and that kid's going to take that and
just run with it
right and they're like neural pathways
it's just i need them to be grounded and
know that um i got you
i got you we're here this is a hard
season this is really tough times and
um dad's working to play in him with mom
and we're gonna figure this out because
they
they can um they can
sense it they can feel the stress in the
air and if you don't call it out they
will assume that stress is
created by them and they will spend the
rest of their life trying to solve it
yeah right
and they get you got to let them know
there is stress in the air it is not you
in fact you're the best part of this
and we haven't we're going to make it
we're having grown-up challenges and
luckily you got grown up assaulting them
that's gonna make it that's right we're
gonna make it that car
that car is not gonna be in the driveway
anymore we're gonna make it yeah
we sold the boat oh boy you know
we're gonna make it yeah and um but
you're gonna be okay we're gonna have
food
and we got each other and we're gonna go
kick a soccer ball out right now
yeah yeah and we'll work it out but
that's um
you gotta be real careful because well
children deserve to know not really
you can weaponize truth in a way that
makes you feel tough and makes you feel
back in control don't do that to a kid
yeah right call your buddy and tell them
you're scared to death
that's why you gotta have people in your
life right yeah and you know and
and but it is good to also the other
side of it is to acknowledge it
you need to acknowledge it keeping it
keeping completely stuffed
they know something's up and they they
think it's worse than it is and there's
some
conventional parenting wisdom years ago
was don't have disagreements
in front of your kids you don't want to
scare them and
inadvertently i never saw my parents a
generation of kids that don't know that
you could fight and still love somebody
right
yeah yeah kids grow up uh parents never
talked about sex parents never talked
about money figured they hadn't either
found out later they had both
i know and i didn't want to know any of
it
don't want to know this i don't know
this